the red throne is back alright so this
is an episode where Flame Princess
returns and so does the the Fire Lord
except this time he set free by Fire
King set free by Fire Lord Don John Don
John Fire Lord
okay please okay these two fiery guys
are in cahoots and they take out the
flame princess they take away her power
and stuff so she has to go and find
somebody to work with and she's like
well Finn was pretty helpful so her
incentive button Cinnabun go to Finn
Finn obviously still has the hots for
her no pun intended and they decide to
go on down and they're gonna try and
stop them and he keeps trying to you
know he can now touch her now and stuff
but she's not having any of it so
through all these battles and
strangeness finally cinnamon bun is kind
of the main hero he gets everything back
to normal and him and pretty much Flame
Princess are either now an item or he's
just like the most caring night ever um
and as Finn said he was shown up by
cinnamon bun um you know the whole time
watching this episode it's like I think
I liked it but it was very did it seem
kind of like slow and awkward in a way
the fistfights and I mean 20 years for
me no no like a lot of it I was kind of
watching it it's like I didn't know if
it was good or bad I was just sort of
like yeah this doesn't have quite the
energy the other ones do and everyone
sort of like particularly I don't know
like the action scenes and everything
we're just kind of they seemed a touch
slower and clumsy but I don't know what
that was intentional or not maybe that's
just sort of the feel of the episode I
think with this one they were trying to
close some doors kind of like okay Flame
Princess done and over with
cinnamon bun done and over with think
they were trying to close some chapters
it seems before the show went any
further and I felt it was very sloppily
done um like Flame Princess I don't know
like it felt she felt out of character
to an extent
cinnamon bun again it like a few
episodes ago he was just a total moron
and in the beginning of this one he was
like five steps above that yeah and of
course by the end which supposedly it
seems he finally became full baked
awesome he's like this super champion
and it's like but if you look at him he
didn't actually really do much he
punched you guys in the face and ran
away jumped in while the two guys were
fighting so we didn't actually do
anything there it was just chance then
he came in again it's it's this whole
thing of the victim of circumstance if
you will actually this is like the one
episode where I really like cinnamon is
a contrast to all the other stupid
things he's done just let me well he
comes out makes the great big speech no
she won't be a good ruler cut see as
strong strong in the heart that it's
like this big corny poetic speech
tonight what everything before that
though in this episode that's after he
got baked well his notes he got hit in
the face yeah and it looks like he got
his eyes changed they're not like sunken
anymore yeah I know it's something have
I didn't know what it was but it's like
yeah I guess he was like smarter or
whatever but even before you and I me he
was like he was the one that came in all
I grabbed her on the the fire wolf thing
you know they were running a - Jake -
and and he was the one that came through
you know the prison and got the key to
get him I know that's a couple things
and yeah he got the key by punching two
guys and running away okay so either one
he could've done before you know two
episodes ago Apple wedding what was he
doing it was he opening no he wasn't
gonna she didn't even open it yeah yeah
so it's you know I know I guess just
it's the contrast of they couldn't pick
something for him they wanted him to be
this like I said it felt like they
wanted to close the Flame Princess
chapter and it felt like it was rushed
like you didn't seem like he was as more
because he used to be I mean by the end
I get it where he becomes fully baked or
whatever but lay everything else is
scuttling yeah I I guess I mean you're
right but at the same time I think I was
so sick of seeing that character that I
was just happy to see him do something
confident I'd rather I would have rather
him be like totally moronic remember he
used to have a Jake dog as well that was
a pile of nothing
hmm he was that moronic not that many
episodes ago and now all the sudden you
know he's this huge guy if it would have
started off with him being completely
moronic and then him getting like
fully-baked halfway through and him
becoming the hero for the rest of it I
would have liked that better you'll have
like more of a transition yeah instead
of the whole sets also not of nowhere
he's like okay he's so much better than
he used to be when three episodes two or
three episodes ago he was a total moron
yeah that's true it wasn't like you know
again you could make the argument before
or maybe what you were saying me there
out of order or something when they were
doing animated them but like yeah cuz he
went with Flame Princess and you could
almost be like oh time has passed he's
gotten smarter with her but no you see
him at the wedding
he's pretty stupids number that's my
thing it felt it it felt like they were
rushing to close these chapters before
the end of the season and they had no
other way to do it so they kind of
rushed through it Joey you're awfully
quiet makes no sense no but it does
though it does in a way for me it makes
complete sense for one even though he's
way too perfect for you he's not at all
in a way for you but he's not though I
mean I I really really enjoyed the
contrast of how because he was so stupid
and and silly in the past that even
though you're right he doesn't
do much of anything he's just actually
making normal people decisions he seems
so much better and all the more put
together and and I liked that because
even though yes we just saw him a few
episodes ago at Apple wedding you don't
know how long it's been how long he's
been with Flame Princess I mean when
you're with someone whether it's love or
friendship or whatever you pick up
traits you you you know if you're in
love you kind of better yourself for
that person slowly but surely sometimes
you mean to some you you you don't know
am i Joe sometimes you mean to do it
sometimes things happen if you're
hanging with a bunch of friends you end
up kind of sounding like them having the
same sort of mannerisms sometimes you
know and I feel like I thought it was a
really really great reflection on no
matter what
even though Flame Princess has this like
you know I've always felt has had this
outrageous temper you know I always also
felt that she was good inside she was
trying really hard and there was just
something inherently decent about her
and I felt that it reflected itself in
the way cinnamon-bun ended up becoming
and whether it's like a true love
romantic love or just or just a love
bestfriend love whatever familial love
that that he has for her the fact of the
matter is how long has he been under PV
and he's just remained like that well
that's what I was gonna say that's what
something that you were saying I was
likely that's a good point maybe like at
the wedding you thought there at that
but when he's around Flame Princess
that's like he gets smarter you know one
that can make said cuz she wasn't at the
wedding right or if she wasn't a rose
yeah so it would make sense if we could
just be making excuses for the show
don't get me wrong but you know it
wouldn't make sense that's like when
he's around her that he does think clear
cuz he's doing his duty he's
you know trying to you know protect her
and be the guard and stuff like that it
wouldn't make more sense
you know evil wait stalking with her you
know like what you said with PP you know
yeah let's not go to her she's devious
like you could use her has like these I
don't know about her like he definitely
you know trust her much more and there
does seem to be much more of a
connection between the two of them so
that's my experience no I like I said
I'd switch was a more smooth transition
from character to character it does
first seem like um like I don't know
there is something where it's like why
keep that whole thing about him wanting
to get back with Flame Princess and
stuff if if this is what was leading up
to yeah you know it's kind of like you
know okay like if this was if this was
the episode where it's like okay we were
cementec things you know between like
where they officially become broken up
that'd be fine but they broke up like
whatever twelve episodes ago or
something like that and then he's always
sort of fixated on her and stuff like
that and sort of gone back and forth and
which we see him do before with
bubblegum and then it's like he found
with her and it's just our like yeah
they're still broken up like nothing
much has changed yeah really it felt
more like salt in the wound it felt more
like if anything the writers were taking
the fact that cinnamon bun the most
moronic character you could say in the
series basically as you said outshines
him you know it's more salt in the
wounds of Finn where he's where he's
kind of like he said himself was I just
shown up by cinnamon bun hmm
that's salt in the wounds with all the
heroics that Finn has done throughout
the entire series the one person he
cannot save this time you couldn't do
anything a sword cut through the bars
wondering what time is couldn't the
sword have cut the people knocked him
down
remember he cut off all the hair of
those uh he was so good to episodes ago
I know I
he has no skill with them when I was
going on with the sword because it's
like that first episode even we didn't
know how to use that he was incredible
now he does know how to use that he's
not doing
I felt it was again I felt it was one of
those things we're just going to show it
I don't know it felt very much like
we're gonna show how awesome cinnamon
bun is and have terrible Phenix and it
didn't feel very balanced it felt very
almost one-sided of an argument you know
what happened why why did Finn not why
is he not able to do anything you know
we've seen the sword cut through god
knows what else I guess you could argue
he's distracted by her and his feelings
and stuff but it's still it if that's it
that's not explained and all enough yeah
enough that you would throw off his
concentration and stuff like that if
anything I would expect him to be more
assertive kinda like what he was with
Peebles in the last oh yeah more like oh
you know what I can't use it here but I
can use it here
oh we've seen Finn use his fists before
we've seen Finn use other things besides
his sword before so why wouldn't the
guards come up and go sure dear I can't
do anything all of a sudden but Olson
you know cinnamon button comes in and
quote-unquote saves the day by punching
them what I can fin ponche him pin fin
is obviously stronger for the most part
or more adept at fighting than cinnamon
bun it felt very unbalanced it felt like
these pieces had to fall into place in
this succession in order for us to get
to the end of this episode
it didn't feel natural to me enjoy here
with us I feel like there's been a slow
progression of in becoming a jerk Oh
what are you that I will not argue that
you know I mean yes okay he was a hero
and he was awesome but he's becoming a
teenager if not already like a
full-fledged teenager and I love you Bri
and you know like you're the best you
really are a phenomenal kid but
teenagers are assholes I was the worst
whoa okay so I old people and you hate
teenagers
I
you're the best asshole though okay yeah
your own mother said man you're just the
best asshole you call her a so she says
she loves you it's not a good teenager
it's a she's a great teenager no I was I
was the worst and I was made you know
you make wrong decisions you it's just
such a horrible time in your life your
hormones mess you up and I feel like I'm
seeing Finn go through this horrible
situation and frankly this whole mess
wouldn't have happened if he had taken
like three seconds to calm the hell down
instead of trying to show off for Flame
Princess and come to hell down
to listen right before they went
cinnamon bun was trying to say okay so
we're here and they're here and they're
trying to come up and formulate this
plan and he just like dances over it
like yep got my suit I'm pretty awesome
let's go I'm gonna kick ass you know and
then he goes in and bust the door guy
he's like yeah I'm freaking awesome and
it's like whoa but that kind of wasn't
our plan the reason he didn't kick the
guards asses is because she said don't
hurt my subjects but it's okay for
cinnamon bun to punch them Debbie that
again that's my thing Finn could have
easily punched them and even going back
to the beginning of the series Finn has
never been a type of person to listen to
plans think about that he's never been
the type to go oh yeah let's formulate a
plan you know I'll say this too with you
know you're talking about becoming a
teenager they have been addressing that
several times with Finn but I think
there's what you're saying about balance
there is a way to show this awkwardness
to show these we were all teens and we
know we make stupid choices and you know
I guess at the hormones sort of rule you
and you know you go around you don't do
the smart stuff but I think there's
still a way to balance it out where it's
like there's still this charm and this
understanding to what they're doing like
there's a lot of times where a teenager
will do something and you or there's
other movies or shows that show a
teenager doing something foolish but
it'll show why and sort of explain why
and this it's like they're technically
saying why it's showing why but like you
say it doesn't feel very natural very
flowing so I think there is a way to
show thin becoming a teenager at least
with our relationships and it only seems
to be with the relationship stuff yeah I
get when your team is mostly what you
think of anyway um but I think there is
a way to show it where it is sort of
more balanced out and not just I'm a
dufus who's never gonna listen now and
I'm gonna think I'm right even though
I'm obviously not it's like there's even
though a lot of times we think that all
that goes through team's heads and stuff
like that there is sort of this
progression there is sort of this this
might end this understanding and there's
there's method to the madness it's like
we're not seeing much of the method Plus
haven't we already gone down this path
of him yeah being moronic and not
listening and like I felt this is a
retread and like I said I felt that this
is just trying to close some chapters
that it felt very rushed you know that's
me even if it was rushed if they did
from a totally goof bond because they
brushed a lot of weird stuff out here
too but they had such a good sense of
humor about such a strange sense of
humor that's been really funny and like
I said this one seemed even though it's
kind of rushed it also felt kind of slow
and kind of awkward I said the fist
punching and stuff at first that was
kind of funny and then they just keep
going it's like thank you sure I can get
something or you like that there's more
to that scene that it Keith David and
rowdy roddy piper finding each other oh
my god have you never seen they live
like a long time like when I was a kid
David and rowdy roddy piper that
incredibly long fight scene they have
okay cops
okay REO that makes a little bit twist
harry deed like shot-for-shot in South
Park and then you have them here again
extremely long drawn-out alright
now that that makes more sense okay that
that I give it back I'm not knowing that
though and even knowing that yeah it's
kind of
as much as I love they live and all that
oh I will say this though the one of the
things I love is that this is one of the
few shows where Keith David again that
epic booming voice and stuff he always
goes and he narrates stuff and he's
always these you know characters not
really serious and stuff it's so great
just to see him like oh whoa you know
I'm saying all these really goofy lines
cuz you never see that he's good at it
you know like he can do that stuff
really funny I just loved how you
thought that rowdy roddy piper rose
voices megatron i actually did for us is
that Frank Welker does I think so yeah I
think so if we're wrong I'm sure they'll
correct us um but yeah me but like you
sound a lot like Megatron Debbie yeah I
dig it how much great Starscream I don't
know you said like what does know was
that that's mad hot rock I don't know
what that is either
no you're saying you always get to leave
you're staying we're all gonna stay here
nobody's gonna get up nobody's gonna
leave we're gonna end this me log all
here on the couch shop we're all happy
smile smile happy yeah happy family